every substance is made up of atoms  atoms are the smallest part of any  matter now how do we know the  characteristics of such a small part  atoms have been given a specific number  for identification and to understand its  characteristics it's called the atomic  number the atomic number is equal to the  number of protons in the nucleus  is there a way to measure its size yes  we can measure its atomic size it's  actually the distance between the center  of the nucleus and the outermost  electron in the outer shell you can also  call it the radius of atom atomic mass  is the quantity of matter contained in  an atom of an element  how is it expressed please share your  answers in the comments section  if you like this video do share it with  your friends  [Music]